Republicans defended
Congressman Paul Gosar
after he was formally
censured by the House
for tweeting a violent video
targeting a colleague.
Meanwhile, former
President Trump sat down
for a truly insane interview
with MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell,
where they continued
to spread their election lies.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Watching our two political
parties right now
is very much like watching two
completely alternate realities
or like watching two teams
on the same field
play completely
different sports,
like if the Jets
showed up to a game
against the Patriots
in soccer gear
and loudly complained
every time they were tackled.
"I'm sorry
when you said football,
you meant American football?"
We wrote that last night
and then, you know,
then Jets show up
in vaccine news as well.
We have no bad -- no idea how
badly they're going to take it.
For example, on the one hand,
you had President Biden
signing into law
a wildly popular
bipartisan infrastructure bill
that will invest over
a trillion dollars
in everything from roads
and bridges
to broadband
to electric vehicles.
And the best part was
he didn't do that dumb thing
Trump used to do where he'd hold
up the bill for the cameras.
Like a judge at the Olympics,
holding up a 10
after a floor routine.
That's a joke
from our new segment,
Remember That?
When the president used
to show off the bill
for the cameras,
like he was a waiter
at a restaurant
that had the specials written on
a chalkboard?
Was he signing a bill
or doing story time
at a local library.
With that said,
can you imagine Donald Trump
reading a book to kids?
That's a joke
from our new segment.
Imagine That?
Can you imagine that?
Donald Trump reading to kids
what would most certainly
be one of his books.
So the three key deals,
the three keys
to any successful deal,
one, think big,
two, maximize your options,
and three, know a guy
who knows a guy
who knows a guy with mob ties.
This has been Imagine That
within Remember That?
I will say one quick thing
about the Biden bill signing.
And this is independent
of Biden.
Why do they always
give the most powerful man
in the world
a tiny little schoolboy desk?
Just because that was
the right size desk
for what counted
as tall in 1776
doesn't mean we can't upgrade.
You guys couldn't
find something
a little more suited
to the presidency?
Where is he going to do
the next bill signing?
Crammed into
a middle seat in coach?
Point is that's
what Democrats are up to.
Republicans, meanwhile,
spent their Wednesday
defending one of their
most unhinged members,
Arizona Congressman Paul Gosar,
who was censured by the House
for tweeting out a violent video
that targeted a colleague.
A dramatic and historic day
at the US Capitol as the House
voted to censure
Congressman Paul Gosar
over a violent video
he posted on social media.
The Arizona Republican becomes
the first member of Congress
to be simultaneously censured
and stripped
of his committee post.
The Photoshopped video shows
Gosar appearing to kill
Democratic colleague
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
and then heading
for President Biden
while wielding two swords.
No matter how much the left
tries to quiet me,
I will continue to speak out.
If I must join
Alexander Hamilton
the first person attempted
to be censored by this House,
so be it, it is done.
Well, this probably
doesn't need to be said,
but you're not
Alexander Hamilton.
For one thing, I would be
terrified to hear you rap.
♪ My name is Paul,
and I'm here to say ♪
♪ I forgot
what I was here to say ♪
Second,
I love when these idiots
try to sound smart
and adopt a defiant tone
by using dramatic language
like, "so be it, it is done."
Like you don't sound
like a founding father,
and you sound like cousin Greg.
If it is to be said,
so it be -- so it is.
Guys, we have been watching
a lot of "Succession"
and let me just say I still
haven't seen Sunday's episode
and I've been trying
to make it all week
without any spoilers.
You know how hard that is?
It's like trying
to make it through "Wipeout"
without getting knocked
into the water
by a giant piece of foam,
an obstacle course that
ironically looks like something
Logan Roy would make
his children do as a punishment.
Do the obstacle course!
Duck, Tom, Duck.
So Gosar compared himself
to Hamilton
for tweeting out
a violent video
targeting a colleague,
and by the way,
to Republicans complaining
that this is a waste of time,
this whole thing
would have been much easier
and taken up much less time
if you've just been willing
to step forward
and say it was
a deeply stupid tweet.
But to be fair,
he is a deeply stupid man.
Instead, we all had
to be subjected
to the theater
of the aggrieved
from the dumbest people
in politics.
Take, for example,
what I like to call
the "Erts," Louie Gohmert
and Lauren Boebert,
whose last names
both sound like insults.
Boebert sounds like something
a New Yorker would yell
at a out of towner who stands
at the top of the escalator.
"Hey, get out of the way,
you Boebert.
People got jobs in this city!"
We've said this before,
but her name sounds
like a Dilbert character
who refuses to get vaccinated.
The joke would be
something dumb
like the vaccines
have chips in them.
And then Dilbert would say
what flavor are they?
Ranch or sour cream?
Which is why
I'm team Peanuts all the way.
Lucy would never have stood
for this [bleep].
If she had to deal
with the modern GOP,
she'd reopen
her psychiatry booth
and jack the fee up
to 15 cents.
You know what? I think we maybe
landed that tangent.
Could we get a score
from the judges?
A three?!
Sure, but you're biased.
The point, once again, is that
while Democrats were focused
on signing a wildly popular
infrastructure bill into law,
these lunatics were defending
the insane behavior
of one of their most
unhinged and reckless members.
Gohmert offered perhaps
the dumbest defense,
claiming he tried
to freeze the video
to see the violence
but couldn't find it.
I looked at the video enemy
and was trying to figure out --
I-I couldn't see.
I'm told if you stop it
frame by frame,
you can see what Democrat
friends are talking about.
I couldn't see it.
I tried to freeze frame,
but I didn't see the violence
being talked about.
These are our elected
representatives
and they sound like grandpas
who accidentally Facetime you
while they're on the toilet.
My friend sent me
a funny cat video,
but I couldn't see
the cat fall off the sofa.
Then I tried to freeze frame.
I took a picture of my thumb.
And then there was Matt Gaetz
who tried to dismiss the video
in question as just a cartoon
while neglecting to mention
that it was
specifically doctored
to make AOC
the target of violence.
I am no expert
on Japanese anime,
but I am told and I do believe
that it is not real.
Anime is fiction
to the point of the absurd.
It's not really my thing,
and it does glorify violence,
but often
to symbolize conflict,
not realistic harm
to another person.
Next week, we might be indicting
the Wile E. Coyote for --
for an explosive ordinance
against the Roadrunner.
All right, first of all,
he's either the coyote
or Wile E. Coyote.
He's not the Wile E. Coyote.
There aren't other
Wile E. Coyotes
walking around.
Thank God, that would be
a living hell for them.
Wile E. Coyote, eh,
you catch that Roadrunner yet?
I'm not that one.
I'm a different one.
Look, am I going to get
this bank loan or not?
But here's
the more important point.
Don't tell anyone
I wrote that part.
Shut up! Shut up!
But here,
oh, I'm -- I'll be there,
give me one more second.
Here is the most
important point.
No one is objecting
to the existence of cartoons
in general. You...[bleep]
I forgot this one was coming.
I forgot this was coming.
Wait, I want to give this
a fair shot.
Let me reboot.
Pretend I've made
a really good point.
We're all serious.
But here's
the more important point,
no one is objecting
to the existence of cartoons
in general, you blockhead.
Peanuts callback!
Peanuts, incidentally,
what we're going to pay
the writer who wrote that.
There's more?
We all get what anime is,
we understand
that it's fiction.
That's not the issue.
Gosar tweeted a video
with his face on a character
who killed another character
with AOC's face on it.
If you did that at
any other job,
you'd get fired immediately.
Hey, Seth, is this a bad time
to tell you
that I posted a cartoon
in the break room
where you get crushed
by a rock like Wile E. Coyote?
Wally, why did you do that?
Well, I was mad
I didn't get any lines
in "A Closer Look" this week.
Well, are you happy now?
Meep, meep.
Oh, I'm sorry,
is Paul Gosar the only one
who's allowed to be
Looney Tunes?
And that's a landed tangent.
Judges?
Our political system
can't function like this,
where one party,
for all its many flaws,
tries to govern responsibly
and the other wants
to burn everything down,
and there's a through line here
because the same people
defending Gosar are the ones
who tried to overturn
the election on January 6th.
Gosar himself
as one of the most prominent
leaders of that movement,
repeatedly claiming that secret
sources within the government
had told him that
the election was stolen,
although he clearly sounded
like he had no idea
what he was talking about.
If it's what I've been told
and I had people
come to me
early hours of the day after
from the Security
Exchange fraud department
to the CIA fraud department,
that between 450
and 700,000 ballots
were altered
in the state of Arizona.
The day after the election,
I was contacted
by two individuals.
One had expected security
and fraud
jobs with the banking world.
The other one goes from fraud
from the Department of Defense.
I'm sorry, you couldn't remember
the word jobs?
When you stumble that badly
on a word
that simple
it's pretty obvious,
you're just making this
[bleep] up as you go.
I tried that once in sixth grade
when I forgot
to do my math homework
and it didn't go well.
Mr. Myers,
where's your calculus homework?
Well, it was eaten
by my, uh, hairy pet thing?
What's it called?
Uh, four legs,
uh, always going grr, you know.
Also sixth grade seems young
for calculus.
Also, I like how the details in
his story keep changing.
From the Security Exchange
fraud department
to the CIA fraud department.
The other one goes from fraud
from the Department of Defense.
Which is it? The CIA
fraud department
or someone who does fraud
for the Department of Defense?
Also, it doesn't matter
since neither of them exist.
I think your bank
must have just called you
about some weird charges
and you got confused.
Hello, Mr. Gosar, I'm from
the Chase Fraud Department.
We wanted to let you know about
a suspicious $10,000 charge
from something called
Anime Photoshop Services.
No, that's a good charge.
I paid them. They do good work.
Sadly, this is not
a fringe movement.
These people are the core
of the modern GOP.
A majority of House Republicans
voted to stand with Gosar,
and a majority voted
to overturn the 2020 election.
In fact, the supposed
leader of their party,
former President Trump,
actually sat down
for an interview at Mar a Lago
with one of the most unhinged
conspiracy theories out there,
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell,
where they squeezed
into tiny chairs
that I'm guessing were designed
for Cabbage Patch dolls
and bandied about the same B.S.
about the election.
Although shockingly,
from what I can tell,
Lindell did most of the talking.
A year ago, we watched
the biggest crime in history
unfold right before our eyes.
You've compared it
to a robbing of a diamond store
and they were --
they were caught
and we had enough evidence,
I believe, to pass it out
to three hundred
and some million people.
Here, you take a piece,
you take a piece.
No judges, including the Supreme
Court, looked at the evidence.
They just kicked the can down
the road and said,
We're at no standing,
no standing.
And do you think that
all that could have happened
without the corrupt media?
I mean, that was
the big cover up.
In closing,
I want to say there's,
you know, back to
the election of 2020.
I want to thank you and everyone
does for standing firm on that.
And we're going to it
to get it gone.
I've said going to melt
down the machines
and use them
in the prison bars.
It's very interesting.
I mean, that's a very good idea.
Oh, is it?
You think that's a good idea?
Melting down the voting machines
and using them as prison bars?
It sounds like an idea
Magneto would reject
for being too crazy.
I don't understand,
Pillow Master.
Say your idea again.
We're going to melt down
all the voting machines
and use them in prison
to make da bars.
Also, that's the most
I've ever seen
Donald Trump let someone else
talk in an interview,
even he's like, this guy's
out of his [bleep] mind.
Does make it extra funny
that he's in a tuxedo.
Trump looks like a guy
whose limo broke down
on the way home from the opera
and nodding politely as a guy
on the subway
explains to him how pizza rat
was actually a government
mind control operation.
You see, the CIA trained
the rats to eat the pizza,
so we'd all be distracted
while they hack
the voting machines to make
Joe Biden president for life.
That's very interesting.
This is what
the modern Republican Party is.
There's no behavior
to grotesque for them
to defend as five years
of Donald Trump proved.
And yet, as Paul Gosar
proved again,
it's a movement
fueled by conspiracy theories
and fantasies of persecution
focused
primarily by trying
to overturn elections
instead of just doing their, um,
doing their,
what do you call them?
Jobs?
-Thank you.
This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over two million
meals a year to men,
women, and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.